le photographe Georges zimbal a
immortalisé en noir et blanc les gens de
la rue mais aussi des célébrités son
fils matt est déterminé à garder sa
mémoire vivante veut avoir le intime
veut avoir une action avec le sujet ça
c'est pour lui ça c'est le plus
important de choses si quelqu'un est
fameuse c'est pas important
néo Massachusetts George zimboard amorce
sa carrière à New York où il travaille
pour des journaux et des revues
en 1954 il réalise cette célèbre photo
de Marilyn Monroe alors en tournage du
film cet Andre flexion George et l'effet
beaucoup plus que ça et vraiment ce qui
fournit pour moi c'est important c'est
son travail personnel il avait un regard
très rapide mais tordre installer au
Canada depuis le début des années 70 il
adopte Montréal au début des années 80
dans son portfolio des photographies de
personnalités importantes comme le
président Genève Kennedy dans leur
travail au moment où ils étaient sur tel
lieu il est allé chercher la photo il
est réussissait à joindre l'intime et le
public et les œuvres de Georges zimbal
ont été présentées entre autres à New
York Houston et Tokyo
le Musée des beaux-arts de Montréal lui
consacre une exposition en 2015 l'année
suivante le documentaire zimbolesume
co-réalisé par son fils rend hommage à
ses grandes humanistes humaniste c'est
le mot là elle avait beaucoup de respect
pour les gens et essayer de transmettre
leur
vie fidèle à son amour pour les images
inoubliables Georges zimbal est décédé à
l'âge de 93 ans en écoutant pour une
dernière fois Glenn Gould jouer back
[Musique]
Chartier Radio-Canada Montréal